here we go to the beauty object part
height and weight how my height and
weight or guys height and weight your
height and weight oh gosh are y'all
serious I'm going there sure I'm
and I weigh I'll be honest 190 okay my
chick's 58 she weighs about 130 yeah I
know I I know I need to lose weight yeah
yeah that's that's really important to
guys like the Optics of femin and beauty
and attraction are all tied in to the uh
wait it's just a fact of life you know
the whole you're beautiful at any size
is [__] yeah ain't nobody buying
that and you're educated you got your
house you got your Tesla you got the
good income and all that good stuff you
know how to move more and eat better
yeah nobody needs to tell you that right
so therapists and all like all that
other stuff I would fire the therapist
and get a gym membership that'll that'll
solve two problems for you the need to
talk to somebody because the iron will
never lie to you the picking up of the
weights or the machines will never lie
to you like 25 lbs is always 25 lbs
right it will never lie to you it will
tell you the exact truth and it will
improve everything about your life right
you'll feel better you'll move better
you'll sleep better everything's better
in your life you know you lose the
weight you know you be so and then
there's of course you know the
attractive quality of you know of all
those things that sort of tie in with
that so I would I would definitely put a
huge priority on that huge huge prior
you know like prob number one in this
all day long guys don't give a [__]
about your car they don't give a [__]
about your you the value of your house
it's hey when she's walking away from me
on the beach and I'm looking at her ass
do her cheeks wave at me like that when
she's walking you know like this is what
we're thinking about we never look at a
degree on the wall and be like oh dude
you see that degree on the wall it's so
hot oh that's not what guys want that's
not what guys want yes so if you want to
a guy you know to to stick to you and to
commit to you which is what you're
looking for like you want a guy you know
you've made that clear then you have to
give what you know you have to give the
guys what they want yeah I I I actually
started going to the gym yesterday so
yeah congrats should have started when
you're 20 I should I should have yeah
yeah yeah um MAF what kind of advice you
got so far because I know that you read
the whole thing
too yeah there was a lot um the gym
thing is number one I I I think this is
something this is something I'm trying
to drill into the heads of both men and
women it's the it's for longevity sake
for attractiveness sake I mean being in
good healthy shape it is the fastest
maybe not the it's the simplest maybe
not the easiest but it's the simplest
way to get you out of the 70% and into
the 30% or out of the 80% and into the
20% because if you just know anything
about the demographics and the level
obesity and people that are overweight
in the west I mean it's something like
65% of men and like 75% of women are
classified as overweight yeah um and
nobody's saying you got to be an
Instagram model we don't say you gotta
just start being a fit influencer and
doing any of that but um yeah it's it
will drastically change your prospects
um and at this point that you know with
with everything you shared with us at
your age and your income and you sort of
in a way You'
it's interesting because we hear women
that will say yeah I'd settle for a guy
that makes X settle for a guy that makes
y but you have to really actively fight
your internal biological hardwiring to
be okay with that you naturally would
still want a guy that's on your level
preferably above it right diagonal or up
maybe across so that's a conscious thing
that you've got to do is fight that sort
of hypergamous urge to think well I want
a guy that makes as much money or he's
got bigger house and a bigger car and
things like that so all of these things
that you've built up over time are still
kind of working against you because once
you've achieved that socioeconomic
status it's you don't really come down
from that once you're kind of there
you're just kind of there and so the
best way to combat that is
to focus on what guys really focus on
what the guys really look for which is
you know the surface and the
superficiality and sort of the the
attractiveness from a physical
standpoint but all these other soft SK
that we talking about too um finding
ways to sort of mind and be filtered
when you that certain those things like
pop up just I don't know what you got to
do if you've gotta kind of like pinch
yourself in instead of saying it or
whatever it is you have to do but sort
of starting to regulate that and it'll
come with time and it'll come with
practice but um you're certainly on the
right track it's thank you you've
recognized it and now it's you know I
tell I tell this to to my guys all the
time the only the only thing separating
you from where you are and where you
want to be is the work that it takes to
get there so do likewise thank you thank
you um the biggest advantage that you
have do you know what it is on the
sexual Marketplace no you don't have
kids that's true it's a huge that's huge
guys do not want to deal with women that
have kids from multiple dudes it's like
common it is so common women will have
two three four kids sometimes from two
three four different guys MH right and
because women get custody 80% of the
time the you know the kids are with the
mom almost always so it's nearly
impossible for the guy to date her so he
has to go in there and play the role of
daddy she's not really looking for a guy
she's looking for help right yes and
because you got your own money and you
got your career and you don't have any
kids there's I guarantee there's guys
out there that're like I've you know
I've dealt with enough single moms
multiple times that if I can find a
chick that doesn't have kids I will pick
her over some chick with three kids
that's hot as
hell okay yeah now I'm not saying you
know just Le be like yeah I forget said
that I got this huge Advantage have that
have that huge you know have that huge
Advantage but get your weight down to a
healthy weight too so that you've got
the Optics of like full-on Beauty
because then awesome because then you'll
be in a position where you could legit
you know the next couple years you know
if you get that weight down put yourself
in a position where you meet a guy
that's pretty close like you saying that
I make about a buck 50 and I'm willing
to dat a guy that makes 50 that's good
cuz I was kind of expecting to be a
little bit more you know deluded to the
Sens World he's got to make at least 150
or 100,000 if you're willing to date a
guy that makes 50 there's loads of guys
out there that make $50,000 a year loads
and loads and loads and loads and loads
of guys that are taller than you that
have decent jobs that are good men
probably good at being men they might
not be the most socially calibrated know
how to deal you know with dating like
they probably don't watch our stuff I
mean they're not going to be that kind
of guy usually but you'll find loads and
loads of guys out there that that will
appreciate a gal that doesn't bring some
other dude's kids to the table cuz guys
will be on dating apps and they're like
my three awesome kids or my four little
superheroes and you know guys are
thinking yeah right like your [__]
superheroes are better than you know
Becky that I had to deal with for four
years yes right well thank you for the
advice I really appreciate it guys I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out